HENRY SHACKLETON: Be
a long 15 minutes.
There you go.
All right, hello everybody.
My name's Henry and today,
I'll be presenting my findings
on an experiment that I
conducted with my lab partner
Adin over there.
Thank you, Adin
During our experiment,
we determined the angular
dependency of the scattering
rate of alpha particles
through gold foil.
Using this relation, we
are able to determine
that Rutherford's
scattering presents
an accurate model for these
scattering of effects.
In doing so, we are able
to extract some information
about the actual nature of
atoms and their atomic makeup.
So to give a bit
of background, I'm
going to go through two
different historical models
of the atom and talk about
the different experimental
predictions that they predict.
So back in the
early 19th century,
people weren't too sure
what made up an atom.
They knew there
were some electrons
and some positive
stuff going around
somewhere, but other than
that, they weren't too sure.
Now, the predominant
theory at the time
was JJ Thomson's Plum
Pudding Model, shown here.
In this model, you have these
negatively charged electrons
that sort of float around in
this soup of positive charge.
I apologize for the plum
pudding and the soup.
If you're getting hungry
from all these metaphors,
there is food back there.
Now, the experimental
predictions
that we want to get
out of this model
is what it says
about scattering.
So if we take one of these
atoms and we shoot it through
a material made
up of other atoms,
what kind of scattering
do we expect to see ?
And you can see in
this model here,
we don't really expect
that much scattering.
So the atom will go through.
It might pass through a slightly
more negatively charged region
here and move a bit that way,
deflect a little bit that way.
But you don't expect that
much scattering, overall.
Doing out all the math, we see
that this predicts small angle
scattering that dies
off exponentially
as a function of angle.
This dying off is
controlled by this theta sub
m called the mean
multiple scattering rate.
For gold, we predict
this is about 1.
So Rutherford comes along and
he looks at this and says,
I don't know about this.
Let me try something else.
This right here is
the Rutherford model
that he proposes.
In this model we have our
negatively charged electrons.
But instead of this
soup of positive charge,
we have a densely packed
nucleus in the middle.
Now because this nucleus is so
dense and so tightly packed,
it allows for much stronger
interactions between atoms,
when it comes to scattering.
For example, you can imagine
if two atoms collided head on.
The nuclei would
interact and they'd just
bounce straight off.
So doing out all
the math again, we
see that this larger scattering
angle dies off as 1 over sine
to the fourth of theta over 2.
Now, this predicts much higher
rate at larger angles than this
exponential fall
off, right here .
A small point to clarify
about this equation
here is that this equation is
derived assuming large angles.
So for theta, roughly,
larger than or equal to 10.
This is not a limit
of the Rutherford
theory in and of itself.
You can derive a
Rutherford model
for scattering for
any angle, but it
starts to get really
gross at small angles.
You can actually
see this diverges
for theta equals to
0, which is not good.
So this equation
right here is only
valid for theta roughly
greater than or equal to 10.
So for the purposes
of this experiment,
we will restrict our viewing
to theta greater than
or equal to 10.
And these two models give
us two different predictions
that we can compare
against actual data.
So we experimentally
measure scattering rates
at various angles.
And by taking this
data we can fit it
to both the predicted
Rutherford and Thomsom model,
and come to a conclusion
about which one more
accurately predicts our model.
Now let's talk a bit about the
apparatus that lets us do this.
The first part of our efforts
is an alpha particle howitzer.
This howitzer contains
an Americium-241 source
which emits alpha
particles-- which
are two protons and two
neutrons-- at, approximately,
a constant energy.
These alpha particles
shoot out of the howitzer
right here in a sort of
concentrated beam directed out
of the howitzer.
These awful particles hit a gold
foil where something happens,
we don't know yet.
And it scatters off at an
angle theta, which is then
detected by our state detector.
This detector registers
the count, as well as
the energy of the
incoming particle,
and sends it to an
MCA to be analyzed.
Now, there's a bit
of a complication
in the geometry of our set up.
You see, what we
want to measure is
this angle, theta, here,
our scattering rate.
What we actually
control and what
we measure in our
experiments is this angle,
phe which is the
angle of our howitzer
relative to our detector.
So at phe equals
to 0, the howitzer
points dead on at our detector.
Now, in a sort of
theoretical world
where this solid state detector
is infinitesimally small
and our beam is also this
infinitesimally point source,
we would expect phe to
correspond exactly to theta.
So at phe equals to 0, the
howitzer pointed dead on,
we would expect any
non-zero scattering
to cause the particles to
shoot off in a direction
and not be detected
by our detector.
However, in practice, this
is not actually the case.
Our solid state detector
is a few centimeters wide.
And because of this, it allows
for a range of angles theta
that are detected given
a certain howitzer angle.
In addition, our
beam has some width,
which allows for further angles
that can be detected given
a certain howitzer angle phe.
So this is a bunch
of stuff going on.
We've got a lot of different
things contributing
to uncertainty.
But we can account for
this by, essentially,
asking the simple
question, all right, we
have a howitzer at an angle phe.
What is the probability
of a detection
that we see having come from
a particle being scattered
at an angle theta?
Again, in this
theoretical case, where
we have point sources
and point detectors,
this probably would just
correspond to a delta function
centered at phe.
However this is not
practically the case.
And from simple
geometric considerations,
which I can go into
more detail later,
we expect as a
first approximation
a sort of triangle shaped
distribution around phe.
This is called the
angular response function.
And we determine it by
removing the gold foil
from our detectors, so
we just have our howitzer
and our detector, and we see
how deviations in our phe
affect our counting rates.
Now, again, to reference back
in this theoretical scenario
with point sources
and point detectors,
we would expect to only
see counts at phe equals
to 0, with our howitzer
pointed dead on the detector.
And as soon as we move it a
little bit, the counts go away.
However, this is not
actually the case.
And by measuring
these deviations,
we can determine our
angular response function.
So we move or
howitzer around, we
determine how our angle
phe affects our counts,
and we get something like this.
This is fitted to a
triangle distribution.
Now, we can take a few
things out of this.
I see a fellow in the crowd
laughing at my chi squared.
The chi squared
is not that good.
This is because we acknowledge
that a triangle is only
a first approximation.
We don't expect our data
to actually perfectly model
this triangle distribution.
However, it simplifies
our math greatly.
So we use this
triangle distribution,
and try to extract
some data from this.
The second thing that
we can see from this
is that this distribution
is actually a bit off center
at theta equals to negative 2.
Now, normally, we would expect
the highest count rate when
our howitzer is pointed dead
on at our detector at theta
equals to 0.
This offset indicates
that the protractor
that we used to
measure our angles
is actually a little bit off.
And putting that on actually
corresponds to theta
equals to 2.
Finally, this gives us our
angular response function.
If we replace zero with
our howitzer angle phe,
this gives us the spread
around phe of scattering
angles theta that we detect.
We accommodate this in our
equations via a convolution.
Now, this can
intuitively be thought
as taking these two rates
which are given Thomson
and Rutherford the probability
of having a scattering at angle
theta.
We then multiply it
by the probability
of a scattering
angle theta being
detected by our howitzer
positioned at an angle phe.
And then we integrate
over all theta.
This gives us two
different counting rates
as a function of our
howitzer angle phe,
one for our Rutherford theory,
and one for our Thomson theory.
This gives us two equations that
we can use to compare our data,
given geometric considerations
about our apparatus.
So after that, we are
finally ready to go.
So we take our gold
foil, we put it back in.
We measure at different
angles between phe
equals to 10 degrees
and 60 degrees.
We let a detector
detect for a while.
And over the period of time at
any one of our measuring rates,
we get something that
looks a bit like this.
Now, this MCA bin number
down here corresponds
to the energy of the particles
that we're detecting.
And on the y-axis,
here, is our count rate.
Now, the first thing
that you might think,
and the first thing that we
thought as well, is well,
this is about a
Gaussian right here.
That's our particle, and
everything below that
is just noise.
However, as we found out, the
energy loss through a material
is actually described by a
Landau distribution, which
is a Gaussian, but with
a slightly longer tail
on one side.
What you see here is a Gaussian
with a slightly longer tail
on one side.
So by fitting this
Landau distri--
We fit this to a
Landau distribution
and get chi squared's
between 0.5 and 2,
which suggests that all
this did actually come
from a Landau distribution.
And all of these are valid
scattering data points, and not
just noise.
We further confirm this
by measuring our noise,
by taking our howitzer pointed
away from our detector,
and just letting our
detector collect.
We ultimately determined that
the noise within our energy
range of interest is very small,
much smaller than any count
rate that we care about
in our experiment.
Therefore, because of this and
the fact that our distribution
models a Landau distribution,
which is what we expect,
we conclude that we can
use all of the points
that we detect as valid
scattering data points.
But of course, it comes
with some good old counting
uncertainty.
In addition, we have some
uncertainty in our angles.
We read the angles
of our howitzer
by eye from a little protractor
that we have in our apparatus.
But our eyes aren't
so good, so we
tack a plus or minus
1 degree uncertainty
to angular measurements.
My lab partner thinks 0.5.
I think 1 because
I'm not as certain.
So we take all
these measurements.
We divide by the
amount of time that we
collected to get a count rate.
We graph this as a
function of our angle
that we measure to that,
and fit this to a Rutherford
and Thomson convolved fit.
And we see something like this.
And I think this really
speaks for itself.
This is not an error in my code.
Thomson is really just that
bad in accounting for our data.
But we see here that the
Rutherford scattering
prediction more accurately
describes the gradual falloff
of our scattering rates as the
howitzer angle gets bigger, as
opposed to the Thomson fit,
with the chi squared of 2000.
Now, there are different ways
of potentially giving Thomson
a better shot,
accommodating for it,
may be giving it a better
chance of describing our data.
And I can go into
this in more detail
later, if people are interested.
But, ultimately, we see that
Thomson is fundamentally unable
to account for this data.
Whereas Rutherford
describes it quite well.
Now, there's an
additional caveat
to this chi squared
that we have here.
So this chi squared
comes from fitting
from our Rutherford and
Thomson data convolved
with our beam profile.
However, our beam
profile does have
some uncertainty associated.
In that fit that we had,
there is some uncertainty
in the triangle.
So to sort of estimate how this
uncertainty affects our data,
we vary our beam profile
within one standard deviation
of its fit parameters, and
see how our goodness of fit
changes.
And we see here that
the goodness of fit
for a Rutherford model,
while it varies somewhat
depending on the
convolution that we use,
it doesn't change a
significant amount.
And it certainly doesn't
change enough to warrant
considering the Thomson model.
The discrepancy between
the chi squareds
and the visual discrepancy
you see here very
clearly suggests
that Rutherford does
a much better job of predicting
our data than Thomson.
Which, again, suggests a more
Rutherford make up of the atom,
as opposed to the Thomson
Plum Pudding model.
So in conclusion, Thomson's
Plum Pudding model
is found to fundamentally
be unable to describe
the scattering rates that
we observe at large angles.
The Rutherford model
more accurately predicts
this gradual fall off, which
suggests a more Rutherford-like
view of our atom.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
INSTRUCTOR: All right, the
paper is open for questions.
HENRY SHACKLETON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did you try the fit
without using the triangular
correction?
HENRY SHACKLETON: Yes I did.
And this is another
interesting point, which
shows that our convolution
does benefit our data,
does a much better-- not a much
better, not as bad as Thomson,
relatively speaking.
But it does a
noticeably better job
at describing our data than the
pure Rutherford scattering, 1
over sine to the fourth fit.
AUDIENCE: So the
difference between 2.14--
HENRY SHACKLETON:
And, sorry, 8.18.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see it.
HENRY SHACKLETON: That's
a chi squared of eight
for just fitting with the
raw Rutherford scattering
without the convolution.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
plots that show your Landau
distribution fits to the data?
HENRY SHACKLETON:
I thought I did.
You saw me switch
forward and then,
realize that it wasn't there.
So I switched back.
No, so I don't have a
picture of the Landau fit.
One thing that I
can describe, which
is a small caveat to this, is
that the Landau distribution
describes energy loss.
And this is usually a
Gaussian with one tail on--
this isn't too well.
It's a Gaussian with a slightly
longer tail on the right hand
side.
Now, this is a Gaussian
with a slightly longer tail
on the left hand side.
However, what we
see here is energy.
And energy loss is sort
of the inverse of this.
So we actually fit this to a
reverse Landau distribution.
And throughout all our data,
we get reduced chi squareds
between 0.5 and 2, which
indicates a good fit.
INSTRUCTOR: A different
question for Henry?
All right, let's--
HENRY SHACKLETON: Yep, Shawn?
SHAWN: What was the
largest angle you
were able to use the data from?
HENRY SHACKLETON: Sorry?
SHAWN: What was
the largest angle
you were able to get your data?
HENRY SHACKLETON: 60 degrees.
60 degrees, we collected
over the course of five days.
And I don't think we could
have actually collected
data at much higher angles
than that because our noise
rate right here is 0.0002.
Now, this is still a bit
smaller than our counting
rate for 60 degrees.
But if we started
to go further, we
would start to enter the regime
where noise becomes much more
dominant.
SHAWN: Do you happen to know
how many total counts was
that over five days?
HENRY SHACKLETON:
Over five days?
Off the top of my
head, I believe 400.
You can actually see--
I know the rate here, which
you can very easily go
backwards in the math, I guess.
SHAWN: So if the rate--
HENRY SHACKLETON: This
is somewhere down here.
SHAWN: --100 counts per day--
HENRY SHACKLETON: Yeah,
something like that.
SHAWN: Or a couple
counts per hour.
HENRY SHACKLETON: Yes,
something like that.
SHAWN: All right, thank you.
The noise that we
mentioned here is actually
restricted to our
energy of interest.
So there's a fair bit of
noise at much lower energy
levels, specifically
between this MCA bin
number of 0 and 50, down here.
There's a fair bit
of noise there.
But once you start getting up
to this larger area right here
between 50 and 1500, we
start to see much less noise.
INSTRUCTOR: Another question?
All right, let's
thank Henry again.
[APPLAUSE]